know that you never stand alone
especially now you are a Forester
you know how I feel about what's
happened to your family I feel your pain
as if it were my own
House Forrester is a northern house
royal to the king
are they yes your grace there's a long
and sordid history of hostility between
the foresters and house Bolton's loyal
bannermen the White Hills who knows what
lurks within
I fear my family will suffer if Ramsay
is left to do as he likes he can handle
Ramsay snow he doesn't scare these are
hard times the only way to solve our
problems is with iron and steel what you
do will have repercussions your family
will be a risk battle where they might
be
this is a lovely pilot embolism
hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my breakdown of the new telltale
footage for Game of Thrones remember the
game is being released tonight at
midnight I'll continue to give away a
copy of the game every week until we
find something better to give away so
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it picks up right after season 3
that's why we here Ramsay Bolton being
called Ramsay snow Roose Bolton didn't
legitimize him till season 4 of the show
I've seen this game is supposed to span
to season 5 so we will see season 4
stuff in future episodes of the game
when they release it next year remember
there'll be six episodes total this
wonderful portrait is of our protagonist
House Forrester starting on the Left
let's do a little roll call this is
Asher Forrester exiled son currently
living in Essos might be fighting with
the golden company since they're fairly
notable for employing disgraced Lords
from Westeros as well as Noble born
bastards to the right is Talia Forester
she's the second eldest daughter fairly
musically inclined next to her is her
twin Ethan Forrester I'm gonna go ahead
and say that they're probably not
getting down on the twincest like Jamie
and Cersei slightly less creepy twins
but they're both very musically inclined
he's also listed as being very academic
so think of him as having a lot of
Tyrion and I'm very bookish like very
well-read then to the right is the
eldest daughter Mira Forrester she is
currently one of Margaery Tyrells
handmaidens down in King's Landing next
to her is her mother lady Alyssa
Forrester she's from house bran field
and she's being described as like a
cross between Sansa and Catelyn Stark
then to the right is Ryan Forrester
youngest to the house there's not really
a lot listed about him then to the right
is the Lord of the house Lord Gregor
Forrester he's like our Ned Stark
hopefully he will not also get his head
chopped off and then finally the last
one to the right is Rodrick Forrester
his oldest son
basically the Robb Stark prominent
military background very proper and true
to his family unlike his younger brother
who was exiled so now we get some better
shots of King's Landing as it relates to
the game we're not gonna spend a whole
lot of time here in the gameplay like
most of it takes place up in Deepwood
Motte but like I said their eldest
daughter is a handmaiden to Margaery
so Margaery gets involved with their
cause Cersei backing their chief rivals
house white hill and just to explain the
relationships house white hill is sworn
to house Bolton obviously now we know
kind of creepy fairly antagonistic to
the starts the protagonist House
Forrester they're sworn to house Glover
which is sworn to House Stark but really
it's like white Hill versus Forster and
you have like these other major houses
kind of swirling in the background
remember what Littlefinger said everyone
in King's Landing is a liar so Margaery
definitely playing the game of Thrones
too although I think she is a fairly
good character compared to Cersei like
she has good intentions
whereas Cersei really just wants power
this next sequence in the trailer just
explains the relationship between the
Whitehills
and the Foresters this group of people
these are the Whitehills here we find
out how Ramsay gets involved as we know
Roose Bolton kind of left him in charge
this person he's torturing here
that's not Theon or reek however you
want to think about him he's got him in
a basement somewhere remember this is
the end of season 3 he spent all of
season 3 torturing Theon season 4 kind
of begins with him in the reek persona
we'll see a whole lot of Ramsay and the
actor that plays him like he's voicing
the character in the game just like the
actors that play is Margaery and the
actors who plays Cersei you know Natalie
Dormer even Peter Dinklage all voicing
their characters which is actually
pretty cool
so Ramsay snow gonna be kind of like the
Joker character you know like Batman's
Joker of the game so when he says the
only way to solve our problems is with
iron and steel this is actually their
master-at-arms
his name is royal and Tagore so Tyrion
talks about them possibly losing their
claim on the iron would iron was just
used for weapons making armor it's just
really really really strong wood so it's
just a really valuable resource it's
like the Lannisters gold mines to them
the only thing we don't know right now
is what it is that Cersei asked them to
do presumably it's fight in the war of
the five kings because it's still kind
of going on I mean the red wedding threw
a lot of water on the flames but just as
the Starks are kind of dying down the
Bolton's start to rise up there's still
a lot of battles to be fought that'll
all be explained in the beginning of the
game though so that last Ramsay snow
line you know lovely pallet timber just
talking about the idea of the Bolton's
taking control of the Ironwood it's the
same deal with what happened on the show
with them you know slowly taking control
of the north that's actually still
playing out in season five like we're
gonna see that continued into season
five of the show
so just generally I'll say the thing
that I'm really most excited about is
just having a narrative Game of Thrones
game like one that's kind of
driven by the books and the show but is
like side material George or Martin said
that it's basically stuff that he did
not explore in the books or wasn't
intending to explore so it's additive
think of it as just expanding the
universe just a little bit more but it
is canon presumably if it's really
successful they'll do a season two after
the six episodes they released next year
is the same with the Walking Dead game
like a new season released every year
with the number of episodes per year I'm
gonna start doing gameplay tonight when
they release it I think it's around
midnight is when steam starts selling it
so you should be able to buy it then you
might still be able to get the discount
on it it's selling for like 25 bucks
normally it's like 30 congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner Steve Sonny
you want to copy the game just message
me on my channel for details I'll just
need some contact info so I get you your
copy I'll be streaming the first couple
of games on this channel on my emergency
awesome channel and then I'll start
moving the gameplay to my game channel
that's just called Charlie's Dreams
there's links for that in the
description so be sure to subscribe
everywhere that you want to get videos
for that if you're not subscribed to
your you're not subscribed to my game
channel just in terms of like future
episodes usually it's like every two
months or so when they get a new episode
around this time next year is when you
should expect season two of the game
unless there's some sort of delay in
development if you do have any specific
requests for like the gameplay videos I
do are the videos to do for the video
game specifically please leave them in
the comments just a quick reminder new
mobile links appear if you're on your
mobile phone or on your tablet it's the
same as the links that I had over here
but click here for my breakdown of the
season five viral trailer for season
five of the show that is and click here
for all my other Game of Thrones bonus
videos thank you so much for watching so
let's all high-five I will see you guys
tonight
you